welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode 1 which gives us fresh
perspectives of the avengers history a
child's view of the battle of new york
an evil rich person's view of avengers
endgame and all of it in the broadway
footlights never have i been more
delighted to accurately predict
something in this case what catchphrase
would be the showstopper
i can do this all day
i can do this
and i can do this all day break down the
first episode of hot guys shot by shot
for all the mcu connections visual clues
and easter eggs that you might have
missed and a reminder that you can get
your hands on our new limited edition
merch design inspired by hawkeye at
newrockstarsmerch.com
getting this latest obsession will give
you the added bonus of writing in a
custom shout out for our hawkeye inside
marvel after shows okay so the opening
marvel studios title card has been
updated from past marvel titles to
include a shot of natasha and elena from
black widow on the v and on the m before
shang chi harnesses the ten rings
hawkeye's mid-air twist from the 2012
avengers the move we are about to see
but from a new angle in this episode we
opened in new york in 2012 as the battle
of new york begins making hawkeye the
fifth live-action mcu title to depict
this battle after avengers spider-man
homecoming avengers end game and the
loki prologue they love coming back to
this day and depending on your
interpretation of the mcu's timeline
logic there may be alternate caps and
tonys snooping around in the alley below
this building but you'll notice the city
is at peace at this moment we only see
the first chitauri fly past the window a
little over three minutes in at which
point director rhys thomas shoots the
chaos in one continuous unbroken shot
lasting about two minutes from there
until kate sees the stark tower through
the collapsed wall and hawkeye's same
badass jump from the 2012 film that we
saw from his perspective then this pose
of hawkeye falling backwards aiming the
arrow back upward was the opening panel
of the 2012-2013 matt fraction david aha
hawkeye comic that this series is based
on but now we see it from the
perspective of the future hawkeye kate
bishop as this series is adapting that
storyline to be but it's interesting how
time has been condensed for this show
because in the 2012 film this battle
spans from start to finish from the
moment the chotary arrives about 19 and
a half minutes of screen time as we cut
around among the various perspectives of
the participants of this battle from the
first wave of satari to clint's jump but
here from the perspective of one little
girl that same chaos unfolds in less
than two minutes all pretty much in real
time from her perspective now you could
point to this interesting detail with
stark tower where there's only the
missing r at this point in the battle
whereas in the 2012 film the first
letters broken off were really the k and
only part of the r when loki and thor
fight he could look at that and say yeah
maybe they're just taking liberties with
the continuity of the battle or maybe
this is an alternate timeline really i
just think this is more realistically
how fast the devastation would feel to
new yorkers fleeing and fear the
avengers they were slow motion kick and
ass for what felt like half an hour but
for everyone else they had just minutes
to run for their lives just an
interesting way how time moves
differently for the avengers or as steve
rogers lamented it in game you know i
keep telling everybody they should move
on and
grow some do but not us now in this
bedroom are a bunch of trophies and
medals but are these kate making her a
prodigy over achiever or are they
someone else's because there is a framed
photo of a woman doing a handstand on a
ledge presumably kate's mother eleanor
someone who is definitely more agile
than she lets on and is the kind of
parent who would pressure her daughter
to be an overachiever but here kate's
just an animal lover with the toy pet
vet truck foreshadowing her caring for
the welfare of the most amazing pizza
dog kate's parents eleanor and derek
argue we have to sell the penthouse no
we don't that's that's what an actual
solution you know maybe growing up in
this place you got used to the idea that
a solution would just fall out of the
sky but it won't dare it so in the
comics derek bishop comes from a wealthy
manhattanite family and it's eleanor who
supposedly died disappearing
mysteriously while on a trip to colorado
and derek being implicated in her death
but this series reverses it so that it
seems like derek dies but notice we do
not see that death and he and eleanor
were in some kind of shady financial
situation a situation that miraculously
evaporates after derek's death and then
eleanor's wealth only seems to grow so
it looks like a solution did fall out of
the sky a chitari wormhole in the sky
providing a convenient cover story for
eleanor to get her husband out of her
life and notice how eleanor responds
do you wanna
who are we kidding you go ouch this
tells us that a kate prefers her father
as a parent and they all know that and b
eleanor doesn't really want her own
daughter it's also tragically sweet how
derek first asks kate how much did you
hear as if he was worried kate overheard
eleanor's response to that question and
then after giving her some classic hero
advice he leaves think fast
i'll be downstairs in my office and
later eleanor tells kate to go set up
checkers saying okay i'm going
downstairs i'll be right back okay huh
so what happened downstairs eleanor and
if she was able to somehow premeditate
this it would mean she would have to
know which atari invasion was imminent
to cover whatever she was gonna do she a
sorceress hydra operative
extraterrestrial or just a very lucky
opportunistic murderer eleanor catapults
food up into her mouth both showing her
own physical feats but also
foreshadowing the same kind of fulcrum
trick kate will use with a wine bottle
later a hole was blown out of the side
of the bishop home and chitari charge
kate before hawkeye's arrow takes him
out but since this shot came from behind
kate would have no way of knowing who
saved her here really her first glimpse
of hawkeye is through the smoke on that
adjacent rooftop glen's fight
choreography exactly mirrors his moves
in the 2012 film he arrows one chitari
and then kicks another off the building
but kate's point of view leaves out the
insert and avengers of clint reaching
back to find his quiver empty showing
how in kate's eyes hawkeye is more of a
flawless badass than he actually is in
real life similarly she sees his fall in
slow motion with awesome avengersy music
as his arrow slings back up out of frame
[Music]
when really in the 2012 film this was
more of an all is lost beat for all the
avengers that ended with hawkeye in pain
unable to get up
[Music]
and you'll notice when kate asks what
happened to daddy eleanor does not
answer
[Music]
then at derek's funeral kate asks what
if they come back they won't come back
how do you know
because the heroes showed them what
would happen eleanor was wrong and kate
was right to ask the alien threat on the
other side of that wormhole did totally
come back and incur the worst possible
fate precisely because the avengers
upped the ante and you'll notice behind
kate is the headstone of derek's
relative russell bishop signaling that
derek's family history and his family
wealth could be something we explore
further and we get this great opening
animation showing eleanor giving kate
her bow and arrow that she asked for but
then overseeing her archery lessons
which at first don't hit the bull's eye
but as the seasons progress forward kate
gets older and more confident and has
more success a third place medal on the
bear avengers tower is briefly visible
in the skyline behind eleanor second
place pedestal martial arts classes
where she begins as a yellow belt but
then nurses wounds after a loss then
scene where she arrogantly lets her
guard down and gets poked but then she
wisens up and fights back and when she
hits them it creates a circular target
logo like the logo of this show then
martial arts classes where she's a black
belt and wins leading to a series of
trophies in everything including
gymnastics and despite this collection
you'll notice the framed photo of derek
remains visible at the center of all of
it then you get this great triple arrow
shot all of them bulls eyeing as we have
seen clint barton do as well as li shang
and mulan make the man out of us
though kate bishop is now 22 played by
haley steinfeld she vandalizes stain
tower uh nada obadiah stain tony stark's
villain in the first iron man and she
collapses his tower into a pile of scrap
we've got a friend named greer there is
a greer nelson aka greer grant who
becomes a marvel vigilante the cat later
mutated into tigra
i don't know if that's who this is but
hey it's christmas time in new york and
bean stage on broadway is rogers the
musical it's got a black on yellow
design with the star and silhouette a
clear nod to hamilton the show runner on
the show straight up admitted that this
was inspired directly by hamilton we
would drive by a hamilton billboard
every morning on the way to the writers
room and one morning i just thought
roger's a musical this theater is the
lunt fontan theater on west 46 which is
just down the block from the richard
rogers theater where hamilton plays on
broadway the tagline of the show is it
captures the heart of a hero and you can
see all the signs of critics raving a
timeless story of a timeless hero a
sober-powered sensation a musical is
triumphant as the heroes it brings to
life a soaring smash and flying fighting
musical triumph and i just love how this
really brings steve rogers as a
character full circle with his musical
theater origins selling warbonds on tour
as the star spangled man with the plan
this musical number restages the battle
of new york you can see broken buildings
chattari's flying through it all but
instead with the glitz and glamour which
contrasted the really dark perspective
we saw in the prologue this amazing song
is i could do this
of course cap's recurring catchphrase
from throughout the mcu i'm gonna do
this all day i can do this all day i can
do this all day i can do this all day
yeah i know now notice that suited new
yorker who has the first solo that we
see
that's actually a cameo by broadway
great adam pascal aka roger from rent
glen barton again played by jeremy
renner watches unimpressed with his kids
cooper lila and nate with ben sakamoto
ava russo that's joe russo's daughter
and kate woodward all returning from end
game i just love the mixed reactions
from all the extra extras in the
background one woman like this is great
while an older woman right behind clint
has a kind of panic attack like that's
not how it was that's not how it was we
also have reason to believe that marvel
head kevin feige may have been in
attendance for this performance though i
couldn't find him anywhere in the crowd
yeah the level of detail they put into
these shows is pretty impressive but you
know what's more impressive getting
someone that perfect holiday gift and
this season a great gift to give someone
is the gift of a title from established
titles while referring to them as a lord
or lady established titles is a project
based on a historic scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
lairds or lords and ladies in english
they let people buy as little as one
square foot of dedicated land so they
can call themselves a lord or lady and
in return established titles commits to
planting a tree it's just a fun way to
help preserve the beautiful woodlands
and biodiversity of scotland while
raising funds to support global
conservation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage it's just a
great way to connect to your family
roots so here's what came with my
established title your title packs give
you a numbered plot of dedicated land on
a private estate in ardally
aberdeenshire in scotland and an
official certificate with a crest you
can get a couple title pack for you and
your significant other so you can go to
the rent fair or go larping in central
park with your head held high together
so go to
establishtitles.com nrs and get 10 off
any orders that's established titles.com
nrs or click the link in the description
ironman does the same flight pose that
iron man usually does thor wears a shirt
with norse runes on it and his mjolnir
prop looks like it's the same exact meal
near from the films natasha appears her
top forms the red hourglass logo of
black widow and all the sound fades away
flint clearly still haunted from losing
natasha on vermeer in endgame making it
even sadder when a little girl
cosplaying as natasha waves at him this
just sets up clint's arc in this episode
feeling super triggered and discomforted
by seeing a younger generation dressing
up and pretending to be him in all of
his avenger friends but really the
reason of the silence is that clint just
turned off his hearing aid a hearing aid
being another detail from the fraction
aha comics in order to show clint
barton's wear and tear as we learn in
episode 2 this is the result of all the
booms that clint suffered in past mcu
battles clint correctly points out that
ant-man was not there for the battle of
new york the actor wears a pymtech logo
shirt and we actually chatted with this
broadway performer nico de jesus for
this week's rogue theory he gave us a
ton of details of how this all came
together and now i am dying to see
rogerson musical in its entirety on
disney plus or just take the show on
tour i'm dying to see it when the song
gets to its bridge the avengers rally
together and divvy up their roles for
the battle just like the moment cap
actually handed out orders in the 2012
film
[Music]
we also hear that tony stark suggests
getting shawarma
when we're done this whole musical is
very similar to the smithsonian cap
exhibit or the way the statue of liberty
is being redesigned with cap's shield
and no way home it just seems like
there's this new interest in
mythologizing the avengers legend
throughout pop culture in this world as
clint gets up to leave he does pass an
old man who starts to turn his head this
almost looks like armand duquesne the
guy we meet later though i'm not sure if
this is him in the bathroom the urinal
is tagged with thanos was right just
another reflection of the cultural
effects of infinity war and in-game on
this world and a lot like our social
media takes that argued thanos did
nothing wrong i love how clint
hilariously considers it for a second
now the statue above grand central
terminal is once again that first
responder statue that was added after
the battle of new york we saw that in
age of ultron but we also get the
tiniest peak of the building behind it
that was formerly avengers tower that
was since sold off and last seen in far
from home with an atrium constructed
into it under new ownership this whole
building transition does get referenced
in episode two still no word who the new
occupants are i'm thinking it's gonna be
the baxter building the fantastic four
kate passes an electronic roger's a
musical ad showing outlines of all six
avengers though hawkeye is the smallest
and in the background though still not
as small as green goblin on the no way
home poster eleanor tells her daughter i
know that young people think they're
invincible and rich people think they're
invincible and you have always been both
so take it from someone who hasn't
you're not you will get hurt yeah just a
little hint to eleanor's past someone
who has been hurt before and was not
always rich sounds like she might have
married into the bishop family with a
new appreciation for wealth and what it
can do kate notices all the new swords
now adorning the home obviously from
jack's new presence in eleanor's life in
the comics jacques duquesne is the
swordman a mentor to hawkeye recurring
face in the avengers comics no the fact
that this is her home shows that eleanor
herself might have a personal experience
in swordsmanship in the restaurant where
the bartons eat there's a beckoning cat
figurine just like the one that got on
bucky's nerves in the first episode of
the falcon the winter soldier then at
the fundraiser jack's uncle armand
duquesne introduces himself to kate kate
remembers going to brunches at his
brownstone suggesting that the bishops
and the ducanes might go way back now in
the comics armand was jacques father who
bequeathed his son a sword on his 18th
birthday telling them about their
ancestor renee duquesne hickay the
crimson cavalier but armand expresses
concerns about eleanor and jack's
engagement seems like he won the jackpot
you think so
proud is he
i'm not so sure and stressed out about
her mom's engagement kate heads outside
where she sees that one-eyed dog that
she later saves and gives pizza in the
comics this is lucky the pizza dog who
was actually renamed lucky by clint but
so far not given a name on the show i
will say it's a little weird that this
dog finds kate first like might be
smarter than we think as all dogs are i
mean who rescues who really kate
overhears armand and eleanor arguing
i gave you an opportunity to explain
powerful friends that both armand and
eleanor have of course there are all
kinds of shady power players in the mcu
presently from val to power broker
sharon carter to xi ling in the ten
rings two of course figures we hope to
see soon wilson fisk kingpin i'm
thinking the opportunity that armand
gave eleanor was to take on her screw-up
husband's role in the criminal operation
after his death but now maybe eleanor
refuses to cut armond into the black
market auction that i think she is
actually running forcing him to bid on
what he wants like a normal rich person
it just seems like armand used to be a
powerful influencer in the criminal
underworld but now his power is waning
when kate snoops through the kitchen she
hears a caterer say gary wants to bring
this down right away
ah so later when she tells the server
that gary sent her she wasn't just
pulling that name out of her ass she was
actually smartly listening they
auctioned off a triceratops skull that
they acquired through i assume some
shady means in the fraction aha comics
there is a black market auction that
goes down actually attended by kingpin
and several others all bidding on some
incriminating footage of clint barton
committing murder here the auction is
for clint barton's ronin gear and sword
from avengers end game that they say was
recovered from the wreckage of avengers
compound interesting so i pointed out in
the background of endgame's final scene
there was a mysterious helicopter
airlifting something away from the
debris field i always wondered if there
could be corrupt players in that cleanup
crew similar to adrian tomb's crew
harvesting chatari tech after the battle
of new york and homecoming the
auctioneer describes it ronan decimated
the criminal underworld of this city
almost completely annihilating the
status and power of the head of
organized crime and as the camera runs
across the blade armond is framed in the
background along its edge perhaps
foreshadowing his death via sword but
then this close-up on grumpy armand on
that line suggests he either was himself
or was associated with the head of the
city's organized crime that ronan
hawkeye's efforts nearly annihilated i'm
just saying the fact that the mcu is
saying that there is at all any one head
of organized crime in new york city to
me is a pretty solid clue of kingpin's
existence in this universe or perhaps
now with armand's death kingpin's
opportunity to rise the wall explodes
and the podium's like ah i think i'll go
this way thanks and breaking in are the
tracksuit mafia in the comics called the
tracksuit dracula a bunch of russian
thugs who end every line with brol and
they're led by qazi aka the clown who
works with them in the comics who says
we've got 90 seconds to find a watch
everything else is secondary let's go
bro they end up recovering this watch
and it has a red face and gold plating
plot number 268 so avengers compound huh
well red and gold are iron man's colors
tony stark did have some techie watches
over the years the watch he used to
store his gauntlet armor and civil war
and the quantum navigator wristbands and
end game but this watch looks more
decorative there was that bulgari watch
that obadiah stain gave him in the first
iron man the same watch he actually
later used to pay for strawberries in
iron man 2 but this isn't that watch
exactly 268 could be a clue maybe
referring to iron man 268 when tony
recounts his origin with jensen and the
mandarin or avengers 268 in which the
avengers have to deal with kang so i
just think this watch is going to end up
being valuable either for some important
tech they think is stored inside like
quantum tech access to the quantum realm
and therefore time travel or it could be
of sentimental value to whoever sent the
tracksuits kate attacks the tracksuit
aiming a gun at armand and jack just a
little moment with jack hello
jack is definitely smarter than he lets
on i'm pretty sure he recognized kate's
eyes there i love all the use they get
out of the wine bottles in this fight
like kate punches them through their
slots at the guys she flings bottles out
of their hands to club all of them she
stomps a bottle at a guy see while
eleanor drinks the wine kate weaponizes
it spartans watch new york spectrum news
one with real-life host pat kiernan
returning after his appearance in the
park from home post-credits scene kieran
yes a real-life guy but he is
technically the only on-screen mcu
persona so far who co-exists in the
marvel netflix shows because he also
showed up in daredevil defenders and
punisher but hopefully we're about to
see a few more of those crossovers as
clint sees kate in her ronin gear he
flashes back to that tokyo scene in
avengers end game and in that moment he
was turning to look at natasha right
before that cut would happen we instead
cut back to clint in the present
suggesting that he's probably
remembering natasha in this moment in
her apartment kate keeps arrows by her
door meaning she's hitting those ranges
every day bro in armand's home she finds
a bowl of his monogrammed butterscotches
which of course she later sees as a
smoking gun against jack and she finds
the slain body of armand death by
stabbing really these first two episodes
point pretty much directly at jack i
just think him wanting to inherit his
money is just a little too obvious of an
explanation it could still be jack who
killed him i just think there's gonna be
some deeper layers to this murder than
it seems and that eleanor or plenty of
other people could have been involved as
kate runs away there's another longer
than usual take about a half minute as
she runs down the street has the
headlights hitter runs in the track
suits and then tries to flee down
another street before getting cut off
kind of bookends with the opening long
take of young kate putting her back in
that panicked headspace now the
tracksuits punched the car window glass
with their bare fists now i'm sure there
are some psychos who are aggro enough to
actually do that it just to me reads
like the move of someone who's juiced up
on something may be a micro dose of that
super soldier serum that the power
broker was brewing in magipore but clint
takes care of him and officially meets
kate
come on
dear you're a hawkeye
and who the hell are you
yeah that horned theme is the same music
kate heard as a girl when she first saw
hawkeye's big move in the battle new
york
[Music]
to her he is the gritty reality of a
hero that she dreamed of meeting but to
him she is just another cosplaying
avenger wannabe that he's gonna learn is
gonna help him so much to get to know
better to support this channel check out
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
me rockstar subscribe to new rockstar
some more analysis and breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you